[Music]
we know many of you aren't traveling
home
for the holidays this year which means
you won't see your relatives and that's
really hard
so we decided to bring your relatives
here to see you
in a segment called fun auntie
wow it's been months since i last saw
you and
everything is still so hard but there's
definitely been some good news
you and i have both stayed very cute
during the pandemic
joe biden has won the election 100 000
times
and dolly parton paid a black lady named
dr kizzy to make a corona vaccine
so you know i'm about to take that but
everything else is a mess and that's why
i wanted to check on you make sure
you're eating right and that
all your tinder dates are virtual
because mine sure are
okay now we don't have a lot of time but
first
things first i will not be available
for any christmas zoom chats zoom is
giving everyone unlimited time for the
holidays and
i cannot be in a room with cousin marcus
for more than 20 minutes
even if it is virtual because i will
cuss him
out but don't worry i won't be alone for
the holidays
on new year's eve i will be having a
google meet up
with all of the other former jet
beauties of the week
but even though i will not be talking to
anyone in the family for three weeks
i wanted to talk to you because you are
the most like me
and therefore you do not deserve to be
ghosted
unless the ghost looks like a young
patrick swayze
because in that case ghost me baby you
know what i mean
okay anyway just want you to be on the
lookout for your christmas present
there is a crisp 100
bill on its way to you via the united
states postal service
i used my harlem renaissance stamp so
you'll know it when you see mahalia
jackson
singing in the corner now speaking of
having the voice of an angel i'm sad i
won't be able to hear you sing carols
this year
you sound just like david ruffin when
you sing silent night
sing me a little something right now
um night oh holy night
oh it's in my body holy night
oh that's good we should make a mixtape
and put it in the clouds
so that barack obama can put it on one
of his little lists
okay now it's chilly out today but i
never want to mess up my hair so
this beret it just sits on my head but
it still makes a statement sometimes
white people think
i'm a member of the black panther party
which is funny because i
am oh oh
okay this is my pager
oh that's my italian
lover roberto we never speak he just
pages me when he's thinking of me
i have this because i'm a doctor of love
anyway i know that the family usually
goes to the movies on christmas day and
i buy all the cousins tickets with my
old general hospital money so
this year i'm just going to email you my
hbo max
login information so that y'all can
watch wonder woman on christmas day just
know that i will be changing the
password on the 26th so
if you miss out that's on you oh
oh oh
oh roberto
oh now that's my new york lover tony he
lives here but
i make him ring the doorbell because you
can never let a man get too
comfortable in a condo he did not buy
okay i love you just remember
just because we aren't going to be
together for the holidays doesn't mean
we are not a family
we can always argue with your uncle's
new girlfriend on facebook if we get
bored
i'm coming okay i'll see you next time
remember you're my favorite don't tell
[Music]
anybody
[Music]
[Applause]
you